I'm prosecutor the director of the Kluge
Center and it's my real pleasure to
introduce Robert Mason who's gonna talk
to us about this book which is you so I
trust this available outside this book
is really a it's an outgrowth of his
DPhil at Oxford but it's it's an
encapsulated part of a larger project
that he's working on here is a Kluge
fellow he comes to us although he's very
young it comes to us with a
distinguished academic record he he got
his undergraduate degree at breslin's
college and first in history which is
not easy in 1992 he then had a year
Soros funded year teaching in Poland
returned to Nuffield College Oxford
which is a graduate college for to get
work on his DPhil which was awarded in
1998 but he spent the year 96-97 at Yale
in political science is that right
so he's he's got a mixed and very
profitable background of the theory from
political science and the archival work
from history and he's in Department of
History at University of Edinburgh as a
lecturer so what he'll talk to us today
I gather is is about this book and and
what went into it the long period of the
Republicans it's it's ironic that it's
now he's now talking about this at this
particular moment when it it may be
there should be some Democrats in the
audience but he's talking about the long
period of minority minority status for
the Republican Party and
several of the people who wrote for him
when he applied for the Kluge fellowship
pointed out that one of the things that
they were most proud of in his not only
in his academic work but in his future
is that he is a non-american historian
of America and a very good one and we
need many of those but we particularly
need them in the United Kingdom and
they'll be you know there'll be other
opportunities to hear from Robert
because he's with us for a while yet and
he's got a longer a longer project which
covers some of the same ground but in it
in a more fundamental way going back to
the depression so without more from me
Robert you're on well thank you very
much for that very kind introduction
also like to thank Robert Saladin II who
has done so much to organise this event
I'd like to thank everyone for coming
along here today Richard Nixon and the
quest for a new majority looks back to
the perception of a great political
opportunity for the Republican Party it
looks at the actions taken in response
to this perception the heart of this
quest involved the political future of
middle Americans a group that absorbed a
lot of interest and speculation at the
end of the 1960's in the start of the
1970s it was 35 years ago the Time
magazine announced that the man and
woman of the year for 1969 were the
middle Americans when Richard Nixon
heard this news at the White House he
was disappointed Nixon thought that as
he reached the end of his first year as
and he was the more deserving recipient
of this accolade and he says and he
suspected he mistakenly suspected in
fact the time editors were more likely
to recognize the achievements of a
Democratic president in this way than
they were a Republican president but
Nixon did not disagree with time about
the political significance of the middle
Americans it was disaffection among
middle Americans with the Democratic
Party that encouraged Nixon to pursue
some bold ambitions when he was
president Nixon wanted to transform
Republican fortunes he wanted to
mobilize what he called a new majority
to support him and his party and this
was a bold vision for the Republican
Party the party had spent many decades
in the shadows and the shadows of
enduring Democratic success the
Democrats had achieved this powerful
position as the nation's majority party
during the 1930s when Franklin Roosevelt
assembled a formidable coalition in
support of the New Deal electoral
politics then and later tended to
concentrate on concerns involving New
Deal liberalism popular image of the
Democrats conceived them as fighting for
the people Roosevelt called The
Forgotten man the image of the
Republicans by contrast depicted them as
the protectors of a privileged elite it
was unsurprising then that Republicans
only very rarely won control of Congress
during this period and only when the
presidency when the rather nonpartisan
figure of Dwight Eisenhower was on the
ticket Richard Nixon had built his
political career during this period of
Democratic dominance and Nixon learned
very effectively how to craft a strategy
for the minority against the majority to
maximize the benefit of democratic
mistakes to identify issues where
Democratic politicians might be weak
Nixon believes that at a national level
opposition to New Deal liberalism was
sure to bring defeat Nixon was skillful
as an electro strategist and it's this
strategic skill that helps to explain
both Nixon's emergence to prominence in
the Republican Party and also the
immense controversy that his actions
often inspired so the vision for the
Republicans as the nation's majority was
a bold one but it was an ambition that
seemed Within Reach when Nixon was
president many people agreed that the
middle Americans are a rather vague
construct but in many cases the
descendants of Roosevelt's forgotten man
that the middle Americans were more open
than ever before to Republican
cultivation this is because the
Democratic Party was in trouble at the
end of the 1960s as a result of all the
social upheavals all the political
conflicts of that most humorous of
decades race was a significant source of
these tensions between those who
believed that further actions in pursuit
of equality were urgently needed and
those who did not the Vietnam War
created divisions not only about its
conduct not only about military and
diplomatic strategies it also encouraged
a debate about the larger goals and
larger assumptions of American foreign
policy during the Cold War and at home
there were new social concerns
increasing rates of crime fostered
anxieties about law and order and people
started the talk of a climate of
permissiveness to argue the traditional
values were under attack
during the 1960's Lyndon Johnson's Great
Society try to follow the popular
principles of New Deal liberalism but
his opponents claimed that the Great
Society departed from those precedents
by targeting the problems of a few
rather than the problems of the many and
within the Democratic Party the apparent
shortcomings of the Great Society
encouraged some to advocate more liberal
solution solutions that struggle to
achieve widespread support among the
public so all these controversies were
the source of divisions within the party
among and between leading Democratic
politicians Democratic activists and
Democratic supporters powerful symbol of
the divisions was the chaos the chaotic
scenes in Chicago when the party met for
its National Convention there in 1968 in
1968 nixon based his victory on the
mistakes and the problems of the
incumbent party but then as president
from 1969 he started to think carefully
about how he might revitalize the
republican party by boosting its support
among middle americans though many
people agreed that there was political
disaffection among middle americans
there was disagreement about the precise
nature of this disaffection which issues
and concerns were at its heart which
issues and concerns were more important
than others consequently there was
disagreement about the correct response
to this disaffection Nixon thought he
was a politician who understood middle
America almost by pure instinct
even so he shared some of this
uncertainty when he analyzed his
political opportunity he worried that
his administration was in danger of
squandering this opportunity through
misinterpretation through inaction he
encouraged in the internal debate about
how the White House should respond to
the problems of middle America how the
White House should seek
physical benefits in return for these
efforts this was a public debate as well
as a private debate and there were two
books contributing to the debate that
one special attention in the public
arena one was the work of Republican an
aide in the Justice Department this book
envisioned an era of Republican
dominance the other was the work of two
Democrats who wanted to warn their party
that had faced decline unless it took
action to protect itself against a very
damaging perception this was the
perception that the liberalism of
leading Democratic politicians
historically a strength for the party
that liberalism was now moving too far
and too fast for many Americans the
first book a very famous book was the
emerging Republican majority by kevin
phillips its publication in 1969 caused
anxiety amongst them in the White House
they thought dissemination of its thesis
was dangerous especially because of the
author's association with the
administration according to the emerging
Republican majority the racial
liberalism of the National Democratic
Party threatened to alienate permanently
core elements of its constituency and in
this way it created a new opportunity
for political conservatism this is an
important map from the book aiming to
show the electril college strength of
the emerging Republican majority across
the south and much of the west conceding
the northeast to the Democrats with the
remainder of the country as a
presidential battleground but Phillips
didn't think that the conservatism of
the past generation was the right way to
consolidate this emerging Republican
majority instead he thought the
Republican Party may be to undergo
change in order to answer the needs of
this Republican majority effectively
needed to share its association with the
nation's economic elite
is how he made the point in an interview
he said I wish we could drop into the
Potomac all those obsolescent
conservatives who are still preoccupied
with Alger Hiss and General MacArthur
who keep trotting out lacf air economics
and other dead horses they make the
Republican Party look Musti to millions
of ignored working-class people who are
looking for a party that relates to
their needs this argument was not so
different from that in the second book
which was a Democratic counterpart to
the emerging Republican majority this
one appeared in 1970 it was called the
real majority by Richard Scanlon and Ben
Wattenberg in this book scan and
Wattenberg wrote about the economic
issue that had dominated electoral
politics since the time of the Great
Depression they explained that the
liberal views of a majority on the
economic issue accounted for the success
of the Democratic Party during this time
Scanlan Wattenberg also wrote about what
they call the social issue but they said
have become important during the 1960s
the social issue involved concerns such
as law and order permissiveness and race
according to scanner wattenberg their
real majority took a conservative view
of the social issue and their key goal
was to inform Democrats that they needed
to take account of this social
conservatism to maintain their majority
status but Scanlon wattenberg had a
message for the Republican Party as well
according to scanner wattenberg if
Republicans wanted to win the support of
the real majority they needed to rethink
their conservatism on the economic issue
they wrote just as Democrats must move
on the social issue to keep in tune with
the center so Republicans must move on
the economic issue to capture the center
a Republican Party perceived others go
slow on the problems of unemployment or
the cities or transportation or
pollution or against Medicare Social
Security will be vulnerable
America has problems Americans of
Ascenta are aware that America has
problems Americans are the sent in the
7th will want an actor this
problem-solving government Republicans
must offer up such an image or face
trouble they cannot keep the image of
the party of the small-town banker there
aren't enough small-town bankers to
elect a president
well Newsweek wrote at this time of the
troubled American and within the next
administration the Labor Department
produced an especially thoughtful
response to this crisis of the troubled
American in middle America a report by
assistant secretary Jerome Rosso
identified an array of problems suffered
by middle Americans people he defined as
neither rich nor poor in America these
are people who had unsatisfying
unrewarding jobs with few prospects for
advancement Rosso noted that this group
tended to experience relatively little
upward mobility even from generation to
generation these are people not poor
enough to benefit from government
programs but they were often not wealthy
enough to support a family with any
degree of comfort according to
contemporary expectations and while
America as a whole was becoming more
affluent the members of this group were
not winning their fair share of the new
wealth in socio-economic terms they were
slipping behind and the result was the
frustration discussed in Newsweek and
time and in many other places during
this period many writers dwelt on the
racial resentments of white workers but
Rosso emphasized that blue-collar white
sand blue collar African Americans
shared similar problems and he thought
the recognition of this common ground
might defuse tensions in American
society the report advocated an array of
initiatives to tackle this array of
problems roses interests were really in
public policy rather than electoral
politics but his analysis suggested the
kids could make gains by tackling the
problems of this group central to the
Democratic coalition but apparently
ignored by many Democratic politicians
the rosy report intrigued Nixon and it
won support in the White House but it
also inspired some skepticism among the
more conservative in the White House one
aide wrote that the report was a
blueprint for an expanded welfare state
it envisions a program which we can't
afford politically or budgetarily well
while the debate about the Republican
future continued in 1969 both inside and
outside the White House often
concentrating on the economic ills of
Middle America Nixon caught sight of a
coherent coalition in quite a different
way this was a wide and a deep coalition
of support for him and this coalition
supported Nixon's approach to his most
important problem which was the pursuit
of what he called peace with honor in
Vietnam in November 1969 Nixon delivered
a television address to the great silent
majority of Americans seeking to
maintain their support for his Vietnam
policy the address was in response to
the anti-war movement the anti-war
arguments that were gaining more and
more support at this time they
threatened to jeopardize the
implementation of Nixon's approach to
ending American involvement in the war
the speech was even more successful the
Nixon Hope the White has received many
telegrams and letters supporting Nixon
large numbers of Americans identified
themselves with the silent majority
according to administration polls this
identification often remained in place
long after the immediate controversies
of fall 1969 had passed and it was this
version of the middle American Coalition
rather than other ways of conceiving the
Republican opportunity that tended to
dominate Nixon's thinking during his
quest for a new majority Nixon first
tried to consolidate the support of the
silent majority
in the midterm elections of 1970 this
was a remarkable effort led by Nixon to
boost Republican fortunes Nixon thought
that the right strategy would prevent
the losses usually suffered by the
administration's party midway through
its term by avoiding such a midterm loss
he'd achieve a firmer foundation in
Congress for his agenda support for his
Vietnam policy was an especially
consequential consideration that goal in
itself was ambitious enough that Nixon
had an even more ambitious goal in 1970
Nixon wanted to redefine the lines of
conflict the lines of difference between
the parties to the longer term benefit
of the Republicans he wanted to use the
campaign as a tool to elevate the
salience of what's come and Wattenberg
had called the social issue and he
wanted to demonize his opponents
particularly his anti-war opponents as
radical liberals Nixon told his aides at
this time but there's a realignment
going on he meant that the party
coalition's were in a state of flux new
issues new problems were becoming
decisive in electoral politics he meant
that the Republicans had a chance at
last to display the Democrats as the
nation's majority party despite an
interest in the ideas discussed by
scammin wattenberg
in the real majority Nixon's campaign
did not follow the scam in Wattenberg
thesis because he didn't tackle the
problem of the party's economic issue
conservatism he hopes instead that an
emphasis on the social issue might solve
this problem crowding out discussion of
the economic issue though as the
campaign approached he did order some
action on the rosa report this action
that he ordered was of a symbolic and
not a substantive kind however trying to
stress the administration's concerns
about troubled Americans without
promising initiatives to solve these
problems
Spiro Agnew the Vice President
spearheaded the campaign against radical
liberalism this was a dramatic campaign
often a shrill campaign and you claimed
that Democratic politicians had
abandoned their party's traditions in
his opening speech of the campaign Agnew
said today's radical liberal posturing
in the Senate is a bad as closely
related to a Harry Truman as is a
chihuahua to a Timberwolf Nixon joined
in as well on foreign policy for example
he attacked the officeholders and
candidates who try to demean their
country and who canceled defeat and
humiliation for America on crime he
claimed that his opponents had all but
forgotten the right of innocent people
to enjoy freedom from fear and he said
this is not a traditional election
because he said today in America there
are two separate and distinct political
and social philosophers competing for
the right to determine the destiny of
this nation these elections are another
phase of the political and philosophical
conflict of 1968 a conflict between the
dogmas of the old elite the dominated
America in the 6th isn't on the other
side a new leadership that represents
the values and beliefs of a new emergent
majority in American politics the
outcome of the campaign was not as
dramatic as the rhetoric Democratic
candidates often managed to resist the
rather unlikely characterization that
they were exponents of radical
liberalism still the midterm campaign
did enjoy some success Republican losses
in the house in 1970 were relatively few
Republicans even made some gains in the
Senate but the scope of these gains did
not match Nixon's hopes and even Nixon's
expectations and there was no evidence
the larger ambition of the campaign to
elevate the salience of the social issue
to redraw the lines of conflict between
the parties had secured any success at
all Nixon's quest for a new majority had
not yet managed
translate the dis affections within the
Democratic coalition into any stronger
sense of identification with the
Republican Party
Nixon's next step as president looked
for reforms to tackle problems at home
not as a way to implement the rosso
report but his goals shared many of the
same concerns Nixon outlined some ideas
that he thought were good public policy
but also promising in terms of electoral
politics thinking along similar lines to
Kevin Phillips and Tess cannon
Wattenberg about the need to transform
the Republican Party to win a new
majority and Nixon talked about these
reform-minded ambitions with the
greatest clarity in his 1971 State of
the Union address Nixon announced what
he called a new American Revolution of
six great goals this was an agenda that
reflected conservative skepticism about
big government but it was also an agenda
that accepted a need for programmatic
innovation to tackle social and economic
problems this new American Revolution
promised improved protections of the
environment to reform the systems of
health care and welfare in economic
policy it's signaled an intention to
downplay conservatively say fair ideals
moving instead towards an approach
closer to those normally associated with
liberals
the new American Revolution also
included concern about the structures of
government Nixon offered proposals of
government reorganization of revenue
sharing involving the transfer of funds
and decision-making responsibilities
away from the federal government across
to the states these six great goals
didn't include any commitment to further
progress in the area of civil rights
though the Nixon administration
supported affirmative action English
Nixon gave Democratic voters who are
uncomfortable with that part is racial
liberal is no reason to suspect that the
Republican Party would emulate that
egalitarian commitment and he made no
real effort to increase Republican
support among African Americans
not long after Nixon announced the new
American Revolution before Congress he
met with congressional Republicans to
explain its virtues to them he told the
congressional Republicans that the
Republican Party had spent so long as
the minority party that opposition and
negativity were natural to them they
were its key characteristics but now the
party could move in a new direction as
the party of innovation and change they
couldn't promise to expand the Democrats
he said but they could promise better
policies more imaginative initiatives
but the outcome of these proposals the
outcome of the new American Revolution
was by no means revolutionary opposition
amongst the Democratic majorities in
Congress was one obstacle to success but
many Republicans in Congress were often
ambivalent at best about a reform agenda
that was sometimes a just step with
their own set of political concerns and
despite his occasional enthusiasm about
gaining a reputation for bold reform as
an American Disraeli Nixon himself did
not show much enthusiasm about building
congressional and public support for his
reforms he didn't dedicate my jam' much
energy to that important task and in
private he not infrequently expressed
significant doubts about the wisdom of
this agenda in terms of public policy
the new American Revolution did make
some important achievements but in terms
of the quest for a new majority it was
much less successful Nixon didn't manage
to infuse the Republican Party with a
new reputation for innovation and
activism
and as the presidential election of 1972
approached the nature of Nixon's quest
underwent an important change its focus
rested more heavily on Nixon himself
that on the Republican Party more
generally the theme in 1972 was Nixon
alone meanwhile some congressional
Republicans harbored the hope that Nixon
landslide might encourage the defection
of Democrats in Congress across the
Republican Party that might be a
different route to a new Republican
Party they hoped in vain as things
turned out that such defections might
secure Republican organization of the
house if not the Senate on the campaign
trail in 1972 Nixon made relatively
little effort to defend the agenda of
the new American Revolution he made
relatively little effort to promote that
agenda his campaign devoted much more
attention to condemning the liberal
domestic agenda of Nixon's opponent
George McGovern Nixon spoke of values
though not in the same harsh way that
Agnew had done in 1970 he talked a lot
about foreign policy he talked a lot
about date aunt and he emphasized that
the end of American involvement in the
Vietnam War was in sight he claimed the
achievement of peace with honor
he condemned McGovern's anti-war
positions he urged Democratic voters
that abandoned McGovern has outside
their party's traditions the formula
worked well for Nixon in winning over
many middle Americans away from McGovern
internal polls at the White House
suggested that foreign policy often
played an especially important part in
gaining their support the formula didn't
work for Republicans
more generally instead it encouraged the
phenomenon of ticket splitting Nixon
Democrats who supported Nixon for the
presidency but remained loyal to the
Democrats when they were casting their
votes for other offices
in the aftermath of the elections the
Nixon administration pursued the new
majority by claiming identification with
middle America Nixon hosted an a series
of events the White House where the
guests he invited were people he
considered representatives of Middle
America representatives of what he
called his new majority and in a
newspaper column one of his aides
Charles Colson compared what he
characterized as the anti elitist nature
of these gatherings with the era of
Andrew Jackson the spirit of Andrew
Jackson he wrote Christmastime at the
White House 1972 signified the changing
of power from the citadel's the Ivy
League the wall street law firms and the
mass media complex to Main Street USA
the ordinary folks from the heartland
the shop steward the electrician the
farmer were the honored guests of an
American president for the first time in
generations they were the people
candidate Nixon spoke of in his 1968
appeal to forgotten American the people
he had called the great silent majority
but the larger party often didn't share
the same Jacksonian goal within the
republican party at large away from the
white house at the level of grassroots
politics among Republican activists this
was a period there was a little bit
different it was a period of
conservative mobilization mobilization
had swept through the Republican Party
with the presidential nomination of
Barry Goldwater back in 1964 Goldwater
lost but this conservative absurd
largely maintained its momentum and this
new conservatism was a very potent
source of political energy both inside
and outside the Republican Party but in
search of his new majority Nixon did not
try to harness this energy in fact Nixon
usually did not recognize the power of
grassroots conservatism
instead Nixon identified conservative
activists as potentially damaging to his
cause the targets of the new majority
strategy among Democratic supporters did
not share many of the activists
conservative concerns Nixon thought that
that conservatism was a route to defeat
and it had been in 1964 but many
conservatives disagreed and Nixon's
downfall in 1974 facilitated the
reassertion of those conservative ideas
within the Republican Party and in
looking at Nixon's downfall of course
the quest for a new majority helps to
explain it as Nixon saw things in
Nixon's view the potential success of
his strategy animated his liberal
enemies this was because his project
involved the promotion of what he called
a new establishment and he thought the
old establishment worked against him to
prevent prevent them from being
displaced in that way but what led
really to the crimes of Watergate and
Nixon's resignation was Nixon's thirst
for electoral victory and that was part
of the quest for a new majority rather
than reactions against it as as Nixon
saw what happened well Nixon's premature
exit from Republican politics allowed
the emergence of Ronald Reagan as a
leading figure in the party the failure
of the new majority strategy lenta
legitimacy to Reagan's more conservative
vision for the party and this was
because even at the moment of Nixon's
greatest success personally in 1972 the
Republican Party at large was no
stronger than it than it had been in
1968 and this was despite the tremendous
sense during the Nixon administration
that the tide was ready to turn in the
Republican direction
from time to time while he was President
Nixon talked with his aides about the
idea of creating a new political party
to replace the GOP these weren't
discussions that took place at a
particularly serious level but they do
help us to understand how Nixon
explained the shortcomings of his quest
for a new majority he thought that in a
sad and elsewhere the Republican Party
was an unattractive label an impossibly
unattractive label for many voters that
was one problem another problem as Nixon
evaluated the outcome of his strategy
involved his fellow Republicans Nixon
thought that many politicians in his
party were not skillful enough in the
arts of electoral politics Nixon often
complained about the quality of
Republican candidates according to Nixon
this is why the party at large did not
share his personal success it was their
fault rather than his this is why there
was no general Republican breakthrough
at this time it's an explanation of
course that's rather self-serving and it
overlooks Nixon's ultimate decision to
devote much more attention to his own
political future than the parties it
overlooks his willingness sometimes to
neglect substance in favor of simply
scoring PR points especially as far as
domestic policy is concerned in the end
the thinking represented by the Rosso
Report the real majority and even the
emerging Republican majority was
thinking within a path not being fully
followed by Nixon a Nixon's explanation
for the shortcomings of his strategy
also overlooks the possibility of
strategic madness calculations on his
part his vision for the party's
revitalization perhaps lacked a degree
of promise because it didn't take a
count of the new conservatism at the
grassroots so Nixon's quest for a new
majority was thoughtful but it was also
flawed
Nixon CAD with a great deal of care
Nixon analyzed with a great deal of care
and insight the sources of change and
upheaval in American society he looked
imaginatively
at their political implications but he
did not always apply his conclusion
successfully and he sometimes found it
difficult to escape from the tried and
tested approaches of his political past
that relied on Democratic mistakes and
encouraged Democratic disagreements
rather than trusting the strength of his
own appeal to middle America thank you
again
greatly welcome any questions you might
have think we need to wait a moment and
for the microphone so I think a question
right here first of all I was late so
you may have already covered this but
what place did people of Spanish
ancestry have in this notion of the new
majority that's that's an interesting
question
and the and I think the answer is that
it didn't it didn't it wasn't especially
important to the vision of the new
majority I think there was some ideas
that were starting to percolate around
the White House and there are ideas that
Nixon paid some attention to about the
emerging importance of what were then
termed as spanish-speaking Americans
that was the contemporary term for it so
it was an idea that was starting to
emerge within Republican circles and and
Nixon had a sense that and that some of
this group might be very friendly to
Republican politics over time but it
didn't emerge as as a key part of the
strategy in search of an emerging
Republican majority during the next
administration
maybe I'm just thinking that especially
in California where he came from the the
people of Spanish heritage would have
been as grassroots as anyone and in
Texas and other states they could you
know sway the vote in a senatorial race
or a national election or anyway thank
you it may be one of the ways in which
Nixon didn't always look ahead who as
some of the some of the new developments
in in politics another example might be
the absence the complete absence by
contrast with with this example the
complete absence from new majority
thinking about any emerging importance
of evangelical or fundamentalist
Christians the idea of the new religious
right that became very important in the
later 1970s was simply not something
that Nixon thought about at all he
thought about Catholic Americans moving
over the Republican Party he didn't
think about developments amongst
Americans of Protestant faiths okay
thank you there's another question thing
right here yes as an historian and
librarian I'm interested in which
particular sources you found in the
Washington DC area to be especially
helpful in your research on Nixon
specifically in the Library of Congress
manuscript division which particular
collections did you find most helpful
and what's the current status of the
Nixon presidential papers and Archives -
in College Park Maryland I understand an
agreement was signed to move them to
California but that they're still there
yes I'm not sure I that III know about
the plan to move them and I know that
they're still there at the moment I mean
most of the research for the book was
done at in in college pocket at the
National Archives amongst the amongst
the Nixon materials there which are an
extremely rich source for thinking about
the next administration very full record
I think of what was going on in the next
administration though just some very
interesting collections here at the
library that I used as well the william
russia papers
it's an interesting stores particularly
to think about conservative
dissatisfaction with Nixon William
Russia was the publisher of of National
Review and he watched the next
administration what it was doing with a
sense of disappointment because he
thought there was an opportunity for a
much more conservative kind of
Republican politics so the Russia papers
were interested they're also the Leonard
government papers and the William Safire
papers here which are also very
interesting collections okay
I think there's some questions first of
all at back here if we can wait just a
moment for the microphone just over here
at the back I think about the McGovern
Fraser Commission and if so what did he
think of the political impact that
commission would have on the Democratic
Party that's right this was of course an
important way in which the Democratic
Party was undergoing transformation at
at this time the way in which the
presidential nomination process were
underwent change after the rather
chaotic scenes I mentioned at Chicago in
in 1968 George McGovern first of all led
that commission and he would then of
course was a candidate in in 1972 and
McGovern understood well how this new
system was operating and there was a
great sense of thinking in the next
administration that these developments
in the Democratic Party that was placing
more more control over the nomination in
in the hands of Democratic activists was
extremely good news for for Nixon in
terms of producing a Democratic
candidate who might have difficulty in
securing a majority within the wider
electorate so those are the developments
and the emergence of of McGovern the
changes in the Democratic Party were
watched with a huge amount of Glee
in the Democrat in the White House in
the next administration and they were
quite imaginative as well as is think
well-known about trying to think of ways
in which to so even more discontent and
so even will trouble in the Democratic
Party one way or another in the Nixon
tapes in in the archives in Maryland or
or they found them in other sources
through your interviews or anything like
that where could one find their comments
about the McGovern Commission they said
I think one one excellent source would
be the tapes and at a college park that
there's now a huge range of tapes there
have been much more made available in
just the past couple of years and I
think that record is quite complete now
but also in the papers of of many of
Nixon's aides moving into Nixon's Papers
himself important advisors such as Pappy
Canon Buchanan was very interested in
what was going on in the Democratic
Party the opportunity that created for
Republicans and Carlson as well who I
just mentioned Colson was another aide
who was watching what was going on very
carefully in the in the Democratic Party
just was such an important issue that it
really can be seen throughout throughout
the papers that touch on on politics
thank you another question back there
yes you from identified a number of
factors did you thought that were part
of Nixon's ambition to broaden the base
of the Republican Party and but I didn't
hear you mention anything about the
Southern Strategy you did mention race
but not but not just that that phrase
southern strategy and in light of what
went on in this most recently election
and not only that even before then the
success of the Republicans in the South
I wonder if you would speak to that
issue I think that probably of all the
factors you identify that that probably
has been the most successful but you're
the authority I'd like to hear what you
have to say about that's right the idea
of a Southern Strategy the idea that the
a solid South the so like Democratics
in the aftermath of the civil rights era
would move across to become a solid
Republican South was an important part
of Nixon's thinking during this period
in a presidential level this had started
to develop well before Nixon and Nixon
is as president they try to identify
ways in which he could build on their
southern strategy to the benefit of the
Republican Party the idea of winning a
Republican majority in Congress that I
mentioned very briefly was really based
on the idea of pulling over some of the
Conservatives Southern Democrats
persuading them to cross the aisle and
to become Republicans so moving away
from the presidential level that also
became very important at the
Congressional level as those
conservative Democrats became more and
more marginalized within the
congressional Democratic Party in the
end the margin between Democrats and
Republicans in the House in 1972 1973
remained too great for those defection
defections to bridge and it remained the
the margin remained at two to two large
for any defections to bridge and so
instead we see what happens you know
what happened is that this process took
place much more gradually that these
conservative Democrats would retire and
they would be replaced by by Republicans
instead so that's an important element
both both presidential but presidential
II and at a congressional level as well
but considering the way in which Nixon
thought about developments research in
South Carolina or in the South generally
and in the 1980s in South Carolina I ran
into this elderly black woman who was a
Republican and of course she was in her
90s at that time and she had worked all
of her life she said since the 1920s in
the Republican Party but that was the
Republican Party of Eisenhower which was
business base
and Margaret where Civil Rights was
concerned and on and this woman just was
so upset and was actually crying at the
idea that the most racist racist element
that she had fought all of her life
against in the South had taken over
quote her party and and so I I know
she's long dead now she was a long civil
rights leader down there few years but
for decades but I was all you know I
monitored this over the years and indeed
I think she described about right
frankly but uh their course there are
the elements to it too but I think it's
been very successful this effort to to
appeal to race and to for as to use a
quote of President Johnson during his
administration he had said for years
he'd wanted to to introduce some
progressive pieces of legislation that
would affect his constituents in a
positive way but they only wanted to
hear quote [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I think Lowe's quote and I think
that that basically is that trumps most
things in that area they just you know
they will not get away from that racial
issue yes the in fact the the extremely
low level of Republican success amongst
african-americans was a relatively
recent phenomenon really just dating
back to 1964 mean the Democrats had been
slipping amongst african-americans well
before then but it was really in 1964
but it turned around so this was a
recent phenomenon but it was a
phenomenon that as far as I can tell
Nixon had no interest in even thinking
about how the Republican Party might
pursue a different approach it was
entirely absent from his thinking I
think there was a question down down
here here the front I think was I think
this question was first yeah yes first
if I could answer a quote add to the
answer to a question that was given here
I was in the or Berlin the Nixon Library
two weeks ago what has happened that is
a private library which is being
integrated into the federal system
and that has not yet been completed
although all the construction is going
on as that occurs first the
vice-president it has only the the
papers prior to 52 the vice presidential
papers are in another archive in
California they'll be brought in this
year and then the Maryland papers will
be brought in in a year or two when they
build a building to do it so if anybody
in this area wants to read through thick
sand papers the like without traveling
it better be in the next year or so my
question went to actually two of the
other questions that you had my
impression of Nixon the question really
is whether Nixon miss miss estimated the
religious right or whether he feared it
because my impression is that his
strategy was thoroughly suburbanite as
the Republicans had always been the
Southern Strategy of the south and the
South had always been to go for the
suburbs in the big cities and it was the
Asheville's in the Arlington's that the
Republicans won and then clearly with 75
Cheney and Rumsfeld persuaded Ford to
dump Rockefeller and bring in Dole to
Kansas it seemed to me that that created
the real red state in ours the real red
state alliant but did Nixon not see that
coming or did Nixon think that that is
there any evidence that he thought that
would ruin the Republican Party or
transform it as he knew it and that he
was leaving the fight against it is
there any evidence about what he thought
about the religious right as he went out
of office or it was later I mean what my
sense is that he he didn't see the bad
development was was arriving he had he
had a rather vague sense that his new
majority consisted of the more religious
people in America these were people who
cared about religion are bad values that
vague idea those are the people in the
new majority but don't think it my sense
that they didn't go any further than
than that and all those developments
that we see taking place later in the
1970s as you very helpfully point out
when Ford was president these
things started to take place that was
something still to come and not part of
the Nixon administration thank you I
think we had a question over here first
of all as well think we maybe have time
maybe for one quick question if that's
possible and I think that was one over
here first of all thank you seems to me
that the map you showed earlier that by
Carolyn Phillips is not much different
from the latest you know results for the
2:04 elections what so what are the
changes or what are the ideas that Nixon
developed that really interested or
appeal to the Manu masses at that time
because the map also looks different
from the electoral college map in 1972
when Nixon won everything apart from
Massachusetts and the District of
Columbia but it just looked somewhat
somewhat familiar as you point out in in
many ways I think as a as a foreigner
I'm perhaps as especially and hesitant
about applying lessons from what I've
discovered by the past or what's going
on today because it's very clear that
the Republican Party today has certain
similarities with the the party of Nixon
where it's where it has a strength and
so on but it's also clear there are many
differences as well and if we think
about the difference that the Reagan the
congressional Republicans 1990s have
made the party and now the difference
that President Bush has made to the
party think about all the huge
developments that have taken place in
America since the early nineteen
seventies
a little bit reluctant to apply too many
lessons about what was going on back
down to what's going on right
okay okay